what with our children eat when they
grow up we must improve our food
production not only here but also
worldwide and we need more innovation
more sustainability meanwhile while
consumers demand more transparency on
the question where the food is coming
from how it is produced and especially
whether it's healthy it made the Dutch
presidency intends to organize an
informal council meeting on our main
priority the future of the Common
Agricultural Policy and the theme of
this meeting will be food of the future
the future of food as you have witnessed
we have discussed the position paper
which was issued by Germany Denmark
Sweden and the Netherlands these Member
States explained that an animal welfare
platform would facilitate the exchange
of best practices it also develops
partnerships among stakeholders while
increasing their commitment and in the
end we hope it will support the
strengthening of animal welfare
standards in today's council will also
discuss the sustainable management of
external fishing fleets this matter is
of high importance to further improve
the monitoring of distance fishing
activities it also fosters transparency
and helps to fight against illegal
unreported and unregulated fishing while
streamlining and simplifying the
procedures the Commission presented
their proposal after which delegations
expressed their views member states
support a contribution the proposal
could make in combating illegal
fisheries however several member states
expressed concerns regarding the
administrative burden the proposal might
until I'm not satisfied at the current
situation of our farmers and I
acknowledge that this situation requires
not just a member state response but
also an eu-wide response we also agreed
that there needs to be consideration
given to the development of new and
innovative measures which can be used to
address the current situation in
addition to the measures which the
Commission has already introduced